german is the first foreign language
i taught myself
i had already learned english and french at high school in italy
and discovered my enthusiasm for language
learning and the moment had
come to learn my first foreign language
outside of school
hello my name is luca d  'angelo and
today i'm going to tell you why and how i
learned german
and what the biggest difficulties for me
in learning this
language were first of all there was an old
friend of my parents
who spoke five languages ​​fluently including german and
i was fascinated by the conversations
about history and philosophy
learning languages ​​and many other
interesting topics i always heard
when parents invite him and his family
to dinner
i will never forget the moment when
i came across a dusty book about german
grammar on my grandmothers
shelf i was thrilled that i could
find learning material in german  had found
abe  r in retrospect i have to say that
the book was not a good introduction to the
german language it was more of a
punishment firstly because it was just as
dusty and boring as it presented only
grammar explanations and exercises and
secondly because the whole text was
written in gothic letters and of
course there was  no audio material
but the truth is it was the only
resource you had at the
time i almost gave up the plan
to learn german when i
stumbled upon a new
language course by pure chance called telescope rt the us
teenie this book was interestingly
designed full of colors  pictures and there
were audio recordings suddenly i felt like
trying it all again
i started learning every day the course
was awesome and i had so much fun
that i learned one or even two german every day when i
came home from school
hours per day at the
beginning i had no idea how to get to
grips with the short language sel  I was supposed to
teach bst but my desire
to learn the language was just too great
if you know exactly what you are doing something for
then you will find a way to
achieve your goal after a few weeks i had
developed the technique which was
extremely effective for me and i have
been using it ever since  used the bidirectional translation
technique to learn all other languages
if you want to learn more about it
please click the link in
description falls almost two years
later i finally had the opportunity
to speak german as a native speaker
i am a summer
camp in sardinia and there were a bunch of germans  and i
mean a lot i had never
spoken a word of german with anyone
but thanks to all the input i had received in the
two years i found to
my great surprise to
suddenly speak and like all this
input this passion and
enthusiasm i almost  two years
in a row it had been used every day
n finally
my language skills blossomed
up literally surprised
the germans were how well i
could speak the language the more i wanted to learn to
read, hear and speak people kept
asking me on the beach
how do you speak german so well you must
live in germany  or the funny
thing is that as I said before i
had never spoken german in sardinia this summer
i didn't really know how
to answer the question where my german came from the
funny thing is that we just said
i was in sardinia before this summer and
still  never spoke german so
i didn't really know how
to answer the question where my german came from
and something else
happened that fateful
summer i meet a german
girl we had a great time
together and after the summer was over
we started dating  writing long love letters
i still remember
my b  dismay when i
found your letters in the mailbox and now had to reply in german
after this
experience german has become part of my daily
life yes enough about me and my
summer adventures let's
talk about the language itself german
has a few peculiarities that
cause some problems  first of all, knowing german
has grammatical cases
one says the man is
cheers but if one adds the television for example
one says i see
a tall man the case is
mainly reflected in the article but there
are also words whose
spelling depends on the case for example  the
philosopher is wise but i am talking to
a wise philosopher as you can see
in this case you not only have to
change the noun but also the
adjective and the article but here is
the good news
in general the four cases in
german are not a big problem
first of all  if you compare them with other
languages ​​to be  ispiel
russian or polish as far as the
pronunciation in german is concerned
thanks to various reforms of german orthography over
time the
system of pronunciation has become clearer
one writes german the men speak
once you understand how the
system works it is relatively
easy to learn and to  use
the pronunciation in german is a
fascinating
topic that i unfortunately can't go into more depth here due to lack of
time if you are interested in the topic i
can make my own video
about the peculiarities of the german
pronunciation this now with a
vocabulary german is notorious for
its long  words for example
legal protection insurance companies or narcotics for
writing regulation my favorite
word is beef digitus surveillance tasks transfer law a word that won the award for the german
word or non-word of the year
1999 apart from that i would
say  n that the real
challenge for me was the german
sentence structure why is
sentence structure now too difficult for an
english, italian or spanish
native speaker the sentence structure that the word
already suggests is the way you put sentence up, i.e. how you put
words
together to create meaning in
in german this works a bit
differently than in the romanic languages
or in english if you only have one
paragraph that starts with a subject
there are no difficulties,
for example in german you can say
tallinn is a cool city
that was relatively easy but if you
subordinate clause I think that adds
the difficulties already start because
then the verb has to go to the end of the sentence I
think that Berlin is a cool city
okay that's still doable but listen to
this sentence once an original
sentence from the novel the
metamorphosis by franz kafka
He lay on his armored
back and looked when he did  raised his head a
little his arched brown belly divided by the
arched
stiffeners at the height of which the bed covers could hardly get
ready to slide down completely
as
you can imagine the whole thing can be
confusing and that takes
time to get used to and the sentence structure
in no time at all  to use correctly if
you are a native speaker and communicate
again a topic for another video
okay you should now conclude from all this
that it is impossible to learn german
no not at all it's like that every
language has its own peculiarities if you
want to learn it if you  know exactly what for
and then find a method that
works and is fun for you
all these grammatical
difficulties are no obstacle and if
you study with passion every day
your brain will quickly complete the language
believe me in 2010 i have the
infamous two exams of
goethe  -instituts made around me then
d  concentrating on perfecting my knowledge of german
because i had registered at a conference
interpreting school in
wise that requires a very high level
to prepare myself i listened to the
news on podcasts every day,
read books and magazines and watched episodes of tatort at least
three times a week,
a
crime series the  every german knows
you can find your bunch of links and
resources in my blog because
i was writing on the subject
during this time i
also made friends with some german
native speakers and learned a few
slang expressions
that i never learned from tv or a
dictionary  and i think
that's what makes the difference
using a language if you
really want to speak a language it should
become a part of your life
i'm so happy that
german has become part of my life
it's a beautiful language the e  s has
enabled me to meet a lot of interesting
people
to read strange books to
see a lot more and to have really unforgettable
experiences without German none of it
would have been the same
well that's my story with
German I hope you liked it
and above all I hope that  she
inspires you if you are interested
i will make more videos about
german and explain you in detail how
to deal with grammar, sentence structure, prepositions
and other tricky topics
and finally a question for you
do you believe german or does it
flow
what are your difficulties  with the
language and what topic would you
like more info on please let me
know in the comments as always
thanks and see you in the next
video
[music]